GCD provides us with
two types of queues.
Serial, or synchronous queues, and
concurrent, or asynchronous queues.
Serial queues behave
as explained earlier.
Every closure gets to run when
it reaches the end of the queue.
On the other hand, concurrent or
asynchronous queues have several threads
that pickup closures at any
point of the queue for running.
These are harder to control and
we won't be using them.
An app can have several queues, but
not all queues are created equal.
There is a very special
one called the main queue.
This is the queue that handles
the UI of your app, as well as
any of your code that doesn't explicitly
ask to run in background queue.
It is vital that you never run
code that blocks on this queue.
What does it meant to block?
Blocking is when your code takes a human
perceivable amount of time to execute,
and prevents your app from
continuing until it's done.
You can do this either by doing
something computationally expensive,
such as applying a filter to a video,
or a big image.
However, the most common way of
blocking is by using the network.
Say you wrote some code to make
a network request on the main queue,
then none of your UI could update
until the network request finishes.
We cannot allow this to happen.
If you do block the main queue,
your UI will be sluggish, and
your app will provide
a terrible user experience and
will likely be rejected
from the app store.
We won't have any of that.